Это чисто Американская мечта работал
везде Вот посудомойщика вот в прямом
смысле слова и на Рижской стоянке и
машины мыл 2.000-2001 2002 2003 я был
номер один да и трейдер на уолл-стрит ты
хрень хернёй страдаешь Ну нельзя так
когда ученик готов учитель найдётся а
Бывает так что ты что-то запланировал у
тебя время есть Энергетик самый лучший
подарок знаешь какой у нас будет это
посещение бесплатно семинара в Алмате да
можно в этой жизни смотреть на три вещи
это на воду на огонь и как Александр
герчик беседует
друзья Добрый день Я очень рад вас
приветствовать Сегодня у нас проходит
третий день нашего инвестбант кемпа где
мы проводим обучение и не просто
обучение и даем очень много практики
Всем нашим учащимся и традиционно на
каждое инвестиционный будкем Мы
приглашаем именитых спикеров которые
известны в мире особенно в русскоязычном
пространстве это люди которые доказали
своим своими результатами что они могут
достигать успеха что их методы работают
и одним из таких спикеров на
инвестиционном кемпе вчера выступал мой
друг Александр герчик Этот человек
который известный на постсоветском
пространстве в русскоязычном сегменте
известен своими книгами видео
вся его деятельность посвящена трейдингу
на бирже это человек который с простого
таксиста в нью-йорке поднялся до
биржевого тренера
[музыка]
Итак я не буду спойлерить перед слово
Александр Вам Расскажите немного о себе
Ну наверное
насколько Простая история насколько
история для наверное для фильма Это
чисто Американская мечта Я как все
светские дети занимался
профессиональными спортом и КМС по самбо
91 году отслужил армию и 93 уехал в
Америку 37 долларов в кармане был
сегодня кстати вспоминал мне было на
самом деле 40 долларов я купил пачки
сигарет Я тогда курил и 37 долларов я
приехал в Америку
работал везде посудомойщика В прямом
смысле слова и на дилерской стоянки и
машины Мы успел поработать В магазине
женской одежды везде и потом работал
несколько лет на такси 3 года я работал
на такси потом попал сначала
брокерскую компанию работал брокера
потом сдал лицензию на трейдера получил
три лицензии 8 серия 55 серия 61 это три
самых тяжелых серии в Америке эти
экзамены приравниваются к адвокатскому и
медицинскому очень мало людей то есть
меньше 30 процентов американцев сдают их
с первого раза всегда очень тяжелый
экзамен У меня сейчас мой ребенок
будущий доктор Он готовится к экзамену к
апреля месяца для того чтобы ты был
конкурентоспособным минимум 95 баллов
95 баллов просто чтобы вы понимали
конкурс инвестор приблизительно 500
человек
в медицинский институт а в 98 году я
пришел в фирму 99 У меня первый уже был
положительный год я заработал 195 тысяч
долларов это я себе говорю чистый
заработок мне в 2000 году я был номер
один фирме стал Через год я заработал 2
миллиона себе фирме заработал 6 млн
2001 2002 2003 я был номер один да и
трейдер на уолл-стрит так как тогда
посудило ну многие любят а говорить
Красивые такие слова так как на по сути
дела уолл-стрит Это одно из немногих
мест действительно там рождался да и
Трейдинг многие любят говорить такие
красивые слова и звучит очень красиво
номер один трейдер в мире Ну конечно по
мировым рейтингам Я не знаю но то что я
в Америке был там один из лучших Да
некоторые годы номер один это да те
статистические данные которые были у
меня я не думаю что на сегодняшний день
может повторить хотя бы один трейдер
вообще индустрии за 4 года трейдинга у
меня было всего девять убыточных дней
всего это было документальное
подтверждено в 2006 году
а про меня я был один из участников
фильма Уолл стритворим снимали hbo
перевели на 15 языков это же самый
скучный вообще я люблю сниматься в кино
не люблю бизнес
чисто бизнес Ну как управленец Я очень
неплохое управление не люблю тебе
нравится это да ты любишь а я не люблю
после трейдинга когда ты один ты сам
собой и у тебя нет никаких потусторонних
вещей которые могут идти что-то отнять
санэпидемстанция там полиция что кто-то
пришел политика здесь ничего нет ты не
политики у тебя экран два экрана ты
сидишь делаешь свое дело и в 2006 году я
всё всегда пропускаю через свою шкуру
Так может не очень красиво говорить
по-другому не скажешь да я всегда
пытаюсь ощутить себя в обуви другого
человека в 2006 году я открыл
проб компании то есть торговый центр где
люди торговали на мои собственные деньги
прочитал книжки в одной книжке 80-х
годов была где один из крутых трейдеров
Ричард дэннис вот так вот нанял Просто
людей с улицы и сказал что любого можно
научить трейдингу если он будет
торговать по правилам
Абсолютно верно Это Ричард Денис
книжка очень хорошая кортисфейс написал
книга сам трейдер это ричарданис
Черепашки два года разработали 200
миллионов долларов 80-х годах это как 20
млрд сейчас и я решил повторить то же
самое я решил если крутой В чем
заключается моя крутость кроме заработка
денег то есть деньги я всегда имел в
тренинге зарабатывать я подумал а Смогу
ли я научить людей первое учил Я
бесплатно Я сам набирал людей я провел
750 персональных интервью
750 мы сидели с моим партнером тогда у
меня партнёр был доктор биологических
наук Сергей федотович выпускников
университета мы сидели соседних комнатах
и делали
плохой полицейский хороший Полицейский и
мы прове 550 персональных интервью
отобрали первую группу в 30 человек
за несколько лет в 2008 году уже за два
года в трейдинге мы заработали больше 10
миллионов Ничего мы платили мы были
лучшие кто платим мы платили 50
процентов от заработка своим людям А Все
расходы брали на себя и потом чисто
случайно То есть я к этому времени уже
заработал там больше 10 миллионов
трейдинге своих персональных
ко мне подошел один из моих студентов и
говорит Шеф
называет может нравится и подходит и
говорит вот как вас называется вчера
слышал да шеф Босс нормально должен
понимать что есть кто-то лучше сильнее
чем он которому он подчиняется и он
тянется к нему То есть это не такой
плохое слово я например всегда своего
бывшего босса называл хозяин и когда мне
кто-то там типа сделал замечание но
хозяин он же там вам дает там кость или
еще что-то я говорю он был хозяин
компании босс это хозяин значит он мой
хозяин Я работал в компании Мне
предложили прочитать курс
в одном из банков
я не профессиональный коуч Я не умею это
делать
для банковских сотрудников потому что
тогда российские банки пытались строить
Вот эти дэски так называемые для
управления Я посчитал курсы потом вот
пошло-поехало но я упустил маленькую
возможность
2003 году когда я ушел от своего босса
потому что он меня кинул на деньги часто
бывает индустрии и другая брокерская
компания Hall Brothers предложили мне
партнерство Я уже был умнее Я уже пошел
контракт у меня был я был управляющий
Партнер и управляющий директор
управляющий Партнер и мне сказали там
если компания поднимаешься в течение
пяти лет потому что компания была
практически банкрот Я вчера ребятам
рассказывал и это был антикризисное
управление у меня была большая группа
трейдеров которые Пошли со мной мы были
такие вот Костяк и фирма у нас была 144
в СМП одна из самых быстрорастущих
компаний дошли мы приблизительно где-то
до оборотки там 250 млн и в 2010 году
мне просто до такой степени это стало
скучно но я не люблю корпоративную среду
во-первых ездить Манхэттен Я живу в
спальном районе каждый раз ты ездишь в
Манхэттен и это скучно это 4 часа
времени в общем 2010 2011 году пришёл к
своим партнерам
вот я вот сделал то-то выкупайте меня и
все Потом я четыре года отработал финале
а потом я решил все равно я больше всего
люблю Трейдинг и остался В трейдинге И
периодически 3-4 раза в год я делаю курс
вот интересно для меня такой момент Вот
вы провели собеседование 750 человек
лично лично А вот есть какие-то паттерны
характеристики людей какие-то
фиксированные которые показывают что Да
этот Прирожденный трейдер
когда-то опять же вернуть Денису Потому
что я не вижу ничего плохого давать
ссылки на людей которые не то что
именитые
самых крутых трейдеров мне всегда
говорят один вопрос говорит Какое самое
запоминающее событие в вашей жизни
самое запоминающиеся события в жизни
было когда я отказал Стивен кован это
лучший трейдер в мире 20 миллиардов
долларов я отказался Стивен ко в 2006
году отказал да Он предложил работать к
нему работать и мы сейчас вместе летели
в самолете на соседних сиденьях Я говорю
ты знаешь я там 2006 году там Стивен
Коин отказал Он говорит Он наверное года
три с тобой не разговаривал
на лет 10 и потом через случайно мы
где-то пересеклись еще на одном
мероприятии так вот Ричард Дэвид сказал
весь надо быть работоспособными
адекватным работоспособность заключается
в том что человек тратит время на то что
он адекватно воспринимает То есть
адекватность для меня это ты человек
говоришь что-то он тебе отвечает с
адекватной точки зрения например вот у
меня прокололось колесо как бы его
починить Его надо снять и ты какие-то
делаешь адекватные действия Когда я
делал персональные естественно я пытался
вводить человека от одного вопроса и
приводить его к другим чтобы сохранялась
на протяжении всего времени адекватности
дальше вы стали делать людям мы играли в
игры была такая игра мы давали всем
можете посмотреть это одна из самых
распространённых игр называется сет Чем
хороша эта игра запатентована в Америке
значит это такие карточки с номерочками
так как каждый трейдер это визуалист мы
80 процентов людей визуалы то мы давали
вот такие вот карточки на которые были
нарисованы знаки правило давались всем
одинаковые ровно 15 минут ознакомиться с
правилами и тут ты начинаешь понимать
что кто-то начинает выделяться что мы
делали 15 минут на ознакомление потом
игра рассаживали по столам людей и
каждые две игры
ретировали стол ротация была Мы со
стороны сидели смотрели Я всегда понимаю
как бы как устроен трейдер потому что у
меня уже к этому времени был
колоссальный опыт управления тренинга я
подходил и пульс проверял и ладошки
смотрел чтобы людей мокрые не были то
есть помимо того что мы отсекли
определенных людей ну совсем глупых
совсем глупых людей мы начали
естественно проверять как себя ведет
Этот человек в ту или иной среде
Угу И вот тогда мы начали понимать одну
вещь что в первую очередь ты должен быть
стрессоустойчива Вот например ты сидишь
да и раз вот например вдруг человек
встает начинает вскакивать и ты
понимаешь что когда он будет сидеть и
что-то будет с деньгами происходит будет
то же самое когда график будет идти У
него пульс будет там совсем другой это
научился у них пульс Как доктор
определять Да вот здесь ладошки мокрые
но я не делал никаких выводов потому что
я понимал что эти люди предстают что
студенты простого Тульского
государственного университета пустой
Тульский государственный сектор не
попали и тут приехали дядьки красивые в
костюма в Америке там было 15 лет назад
35 лет шикарной форме крепенький костюме
приехали и они естественно все
растерялись и естественно я сказал давай
не будем делать никакие выводы своему
партнеру потому что мы ходили У нас был
такой листочек мы ставили крестики Когда
у нас были интервью мы делали два
интервью
как всегда как хороший полицейский плохо
у меня такой красивый офис цветочки я
такой на расслабоне а соседней комнате
Сергей Федорович 200 метров огромная
комната посреди Стол стоит как она
допросе Темнота закрыты мы делали всегда
интервью Вечером после человек усталый
его гораздо легче раз говорить очень
много книг читал мне нужно было
психологический портрет потому что было
написано в книжке было одно я же
рисковал своими собственными деньгами во
всей бизнесы которые я иду я всегда
рискую своими деньгами всегда Если со
мной идёт кто-то в бизнес и человек не
рискует своими деньгами я бизнес с ним
не иду и вот представляешь Вот это 200
метров огромный зал посреди просто стол
на столе лампа вот на допросе на тебя
это лампа ты там не видишь кто-то
задавать вопрос и мы потом либо там по
телефону либо там ставим там плюсы
минусы и всё остальное если сходились
сразу это человек сразу попадал на
вторичный экзамен если не сходили то
этот человек сразу попадал мы должны
были сесть и вдвоем поговорить Вот это
было два то есть они играли в эти карты
сет и ты знаешь нам это очень сильно
помогло мы не ошиблись с этой игрой
потому что мы выделили очень сильных
людей лидеры То есть сразу видишь когда
человек начинает лидерские качества Как
проявляется только Когда человек
попадает в среду ты никогда не знаешь
как человека отреагирует когда мне люди
говорят вот я знаю я говорю ты никогда
не знаешь например Когда мне было 16 лет
Я спас человек
если бы мне сказали до того времени что
я спасу человека я бы не знал что я мог
спасти человека просто не знал как я
себе поведу да когда ты в драке ты не
знаешь как ты себя поведёшь ты можешь
там ну пытаться понять себя ты не можешь
знать пока ты не попадаешь среду вот мне
надо было их максимально загнать эту
среду которая никогда не были и создать
им условия чтобы видеть дальше смотрел
Кто входит в раж Вот пока на этом
моменте остановимся игра Она что
выявляет внимательность
внимательность раз скорость два память
три визуальные приспособления 4
агрессивность агрессивность
самое важное Принятие решения почему вот
эти 5 перечисленных факторов Например у
каждого карточки есть если ты сказал сет
и у тебя не сошли с карты все ты сразу
откидываешь назад ты проиграл То есть ты
должен очень быстро эта игра на очень
было прошлые ребятам сделать они получат
колоссальное удовольствие это самая
играемая игра в Америке самая простая
можно заказать она везде есть она по
патентам продается называется сет мы все
эти вещи придумывали сами кстати вот для
зрителей моего канала скажу у меня есть
один знакомый
Алексей Литвинов Он на работу себе людей
берет через игру и он говорит
удивительных элемент я мне один человек
очень понравился Я хотел его на работу
взять а потом когда мы играли я увидел
что в игре он пытается
по-другому так у него цель была выиграть
у всех была цель выиграть он Расслабился
и не заметил что он хитрит а я говорит
со стороны смотрю я понял руководитель
отдела продаж хотел его брать я понял
что этого как я не возьму это не
сотрудник органов это не человек который
умеет себя вести и побить например этот
вот как называется игра классный
инструмент для проявления скрытых
характеристик человека очень потому что
на собеседовании или в резюме люди могут
три короба сочинить 90 процентов резюме
И вообще никогда не смотрел я брал
знаешь как я всегда всех шокировал я
пять лет
управлял Одесском финале и мы были номер
один компании Я просто человек приходил
Вот вы знаете вот резюме я говорю вот
резюме беру переворачиваю
что вам рассказать я суммарно провел
где-то наверное 1200 интервью в своей
жизни он говорит что рассказывать Всё
что ты хочешь чтобы я знал о тебе и все
и плакали люди у меня на интервью и там
Бывает такое там и родители плохо и всё
когда мы брали людей на работу я задавал
всем один очень важный вопрос но ты не
забывай когда я задавал эти Я уже
проработал в Америке 10 лет я задавал
простой вопрос Представь себе ты
заработал Первые деньги твои действия
что ты будешь с ними делать вы знаете
вот как сейчас помню Илья Данилов он
говорит У меня мама в МЧС работает я вот
хочу маме купить дачный участок Все я
больше человеком больше не разговаривал
я сказал все даже если ты все игры
проиграешь Я тебя возьму Объясню почему
Потому что когда у человека который тебе
работает есть душа и ты знаешь это
единственное В чем я не ошибся всех
сотрудников которых я взял базировано на
душевных параметрах они по сегодняшний
день со мной дружит И если бы я позвал
их на работу к себе они все занимаемых
должностях очень высоких я понял одну
вещь если человек Действительно ты
можешь до него Достучаться если человек
закрыт ты приходишь Илюх
страдаешь нельзя понимаю
но я не хочу с тобой разговаривать
я не цель опустить тебя и всех Вот кто у
меня был с душой и Денис зарицкий Илюша
Данилов и там синегубовский и Вова
Павлов и зайцев и всех своих ребят
фамилиям помню и вариант всех и я вот не
в одном не ошибся Не было 18 лет они у
меня еще все на таких должностях даже не
могу сказать должность и вот после того
как они начали играть в игру Я уже
притом девочки с мальчиками
для зрителей канала я периодически буду
наверное вот так вставляться заметьте а
вроде Трейдинг вроде циничная
Техническая холодная деятельность и
заметьте основное На что обращает
внимание Александр это душа То есть у
человека есть душа то с ним можно
работать можно договориться
можно как-то влиять Это что такое душа
это душа это общие ценности вы
разделяете как баффет хорошо сказал вы
никогда не заработаете хороших денег с
плохим человеком вот вам подтверждение
не по жизни на самом деле очень повезло
у меня была все позволяющая мама есть
маме 72 года я со своим сыном абсолютно
точно такой мне мы с моим сыном лучшие
друзья мы в семье все лучшие друзья и Я
всегда говорю зачем с кем-то
разговаривать когда все вопросы можно
дома обсудить просто за столом у меня
было все позволяющие Мама я работал
первая работа была с 10 лет но все
позволяющие
[музыка]
когда я начал курить дома не надо ходить
прятаться где ты хочешь выпить выпить Я
никогда не пил алкоголь вообще курить Я
курил начал лет 17 и что
вот человек просрал твое доверие всё
Мама всегда говорила одну вещь второй
шанс можно дать только семье никому
нельзя давать второй шанс если тебе
первый раз опустили второго раза больше
нельзя давать Никогда потому что первый
раз если тебя пустили человек это сделал
специально он ждал этого момента чтобы
по простому тебя от имеет подставить
обмануть или еще что-то меня мама меня
научила с детства вот одно это то что я
своего сына стал вкладывать то что я
вчера ребятам рассказывал и они мне
говорят у нас говорят мурашки по телу
запомните одну вещь
всё в жизни должно сводиться я тебе
объясню Почему Я ответил на этот вопрос
к тому чтобы быть счастливым
Трейдинг он не то что цинично это просто
цифры это бизнес цифр вот ушел рабочий
день закончился все вот ты их оставил со
своими делами они тебя оставили со
своими делами другого ничего нет и
цинично имеется в виду потому что вроде
ну ты души не вкладываешь когда ты
выращиваешь цветы делаешь там как будто
Антона моего Лена пирожное делает Да там
велосипеде ты вкладываешь душ а здесь
холодный разум руки цифры и твоя голова
должна говорить твоим рукам что делать а
твои руки должны слушаться голову твое
подсознание должно с твоим сознанием
имеет логическую составляющую
и моя мама всегда меня учила одну вещь
Она мне с детства говорила вот с детства
с утра до вечера Знаешь если ребенок
будет счастливым он обречен в жизни быть
счастливым все классно и она всегда
говорила одну вещь Запомни одну вещь все
взрослые помнят только детство вот если
мы с тобой сейчас сядем Да это миллионы
зарабатывал десятки миллионов я тебе
отвечаю что 95 процентов ты не будешь
помнить но ты будешь помнить когда тебе
родители купили первый велосипед когда
ты например там в первый класс я пошел
подрался же в первый же день порвал
штаны Я пришел домой мне мама слова не
сказал ладно вот это
лодочку сделала на штанах и всё и забыли
Никто меня не дёргал а понимал что я
мальчик Я боюсь там за своё место под
солнцем И вот я своему сыну сказал одну
вещь Ты должен быть учиться быть
счастливым Вопреки всему Почему Потому
что проблема чтобы ты был несчастным она
будет всегда я на сцене кто-то заметил
что меня перевязана нога и у меня травмы
после спорта очень много там ключица
трещина там нога но нет не мешало быть
счастливым потому что если я хочу быть
счастливым ничего не помешает А если
захочу быть несчастным мне все поможет я
вышел на улицу на улице снег долго ехал
попали в пробку невкусный кофе мало
сахара не так посмотрели не то сказали
Мы с Антоном сегодня ехали сюда нам
попался такой казах
такая энергетика на старенькая какой-то
машине 70 лет бывший подполковник
полковник Как там второго ранга морской
такой Дядька с такой энергетика 70 лет я
делаю подъем переворот
Просто такая энергетика 20 раз ребята
вам хорошего дня вот такие молодцы и
Новый год и все остальное Вот
представляешь человек едет там на машине
Да там поездка стоила там 830
тенге 2 доллара доллар 50 минус бензин
минус это ничего не заработал Ну человек
просто счастливый по жизни и когда вот
люди начинают что-то выстраивать Я
всегда задаю всем одной А какая Ваша
цель Что вы хотите
200 миллионов долларов делали мне это
счастливым нет нравилось ли это Нет
нужно было мне сделать этот шаг для
будущего Да самом начале карьеры
абсолютно нормально
если ты делаешь то что тебе не нравится
для того чтобы в будущем Ты научился
делать то что тебе нравится Я своему
сыну пришел сказал меч
смотри в жизни все будет против тебя Ты
будешь всю жизнь с кем-то конкурировать
никогда ни на кого не Смотри Вот у тебя
есть своя линия вот и возьми ту свою
линию и иди по ней вот я шел я сейчас
предложили
зайти в банковский сектор и строить дэск
мне пишут там ну вы сможете заработать
10 миллионов долларов и что не интересно
почему я говорю ответил уже на вопрос
зачем я буду тратить свое время
объяснять почему мне это не интересно
они говорят Как вы так приняли быстро
решение а говорю у меня это решение было
раньше я конкретно знаю куда я пойду чем
я буду заниматься и куда я не пойду и
вот своему сыну Я сказал одну вещь
сейчас просто закончу сентон что
Ты должен быть счастливым вообще Вопреки
всему
зуб болит нога болит и все И вот этот
дядька который нас сегодня Вёз Он просто
говорит понимаете что это это ваше нутро
вот оно положительное у вас все будет
хорошо у вас во время снега вы будете
видеть солнце и Радугу А когда у вас все
плохо Вот вы внутри даже когда вам
придут и покажут что-то хорошее всю
жизнь будете недовольны
в этом плане в исламе где говорится вы
никогда не попадете в рай пока не
найдете Рай на этой земле и в себе
поэтому мы счастливым Это самый лучший
рецепт достижения любого успеха сначала
быть счастливым Я по этому поводу
говорил что я видел очень много успешных
людей не все из них были счастливы
Я не видел ни одного Счастливого который
не считал бы все счастливые люди считают
себя успешными Поэтому вот вам еще раз
подтверждение от успешного человека что
счастье это все-таки на первом месте
Давай продолжим вот буквально несколько
дней назад там среди молодым парнем
разговаривали и мы пошел разговор за
деньги всегда же люди говорят деньги это
неплохо деньги это нормально деньги тебе
покупают время которое ты можешь
потратить больше денег ты можешь
потратить боль если ты нормальный
адекватный Да ты можешь больше денег и
времени потратить на то что тебе
нравится делать Я могу сам стать помыть
свою машину вот я еду на мойку я сам
стою и мою мне говорят
[музыка]
что у тебя нет 35 долларов у меня и 350
есть но мне в кайф идут такой степени
люблю я стою сам её там было И всё
остальное люди просто должны понимать
одну вещь что деньги тебе даются для
того чтобы ты смог себе вот эту свободу
пить и твои действия не подчинялись
никому потому что всю жизнь тебя кто-то
покупает все покупают твое время ты
Заложник мне Когда задают вопрос
заложенный клея Нет я никогда в жизни не
пойду на интервью которое я не хочу
Я никогда в жизни никуда не поеду если
мне не нравится но Я преодолею полмира
там увидеть своего партнера вот я сейчас
с Антоном а потом в Дубае там у меня
другой Партнер и третий Партнер прилетит
поэтому
я надеюсь что мы этим интервью я не
хотел Просто чтобы это интервью
укладывалось там успешность крутизну и
все остальное чтобы люди просто понимали
что все к чему Мы должны прийти это
научиться быть счастливым Это очень
тяжело Почему огромное количество людей
несчастные причине они все время ищут
что-то то что нужно для счастья А смысл
другой смысл не в том что нужно для
счастья а то что делает тебя счастливым
Вот и все Вот тебе нравится там цветочки
разводить и это делает тебя счастливым
когда человеку плохо что он делает он
старается найти То от чего ему будет
хорошо они купить что-то то что он
думает его сделает Он пошел ты купил
машину купил Ну что дальше это ровно Вот
это одна эмоция один что дальше все
часто дополняю сейчас есть не тот у
которого у кого много есть а тот кто
извлекает максимум из того что уже есть
то есть у вас уже есть все полный
комплект для счастья просто научитесь
максимум извлекать из этого именно
Максимум в плане счастья Вот веришь вот
сейчас мне десятки миллионов плюс
огромное количество компаний 17 компаний
я не знаю даже сколько они оценивается
никогда не оценим и оцениваю только
сколько эта компания приносит И если бы
я продавал за сколько я ее продал Я
вчера звонит мой Партнер вечером Иван и
говорит ему 32 года на 17:32 года 32 вот
у нас компания там по производству
электрических мотоциклов у нас кофей все
это он движок мне уже просто столько не
надо я за свою жизнь заработал гораздо
больше денег чем не надо И вот мы вчера
разговаривали он говорит у нас там есть
единый Давайте его продадим Ну он
удвоился там за 3 года Я говорю ты
считаешь что это правильно он говорит Да
вот это вот элемент доверия и
очень важно для меня фактор то что
большинству людей 90 процентов людей
деньги которые у них есть даже столько
не надо я знаешь всегда каждый год на
свой день рождения 13 сентября задаю
себе вопрос А вот год прошел Да там
чтобы я изменил Потом я беру сравниваю
себя с собой молодым когда я приехал в
Америку в 96 году то я работал уже на
такси у меня ничего не было Я помню
купил первую цешку Мерседес на зарплату
на работе Когда я работал такси я себе
задаю вопрос прошло 30 лет Изменилось ли
что-то в моей жизни и ты знаешь я вот
тогда учился быть счастливым и сейчас я
понял одну вещь что вот это экстра Там
шесть нулей один миллион или плюс один
миллион он в моей жизни ничего не делает
мне вот сказали вот вы ведете четыре
семинара в год я веду всего четыре
семинара в год женщина вчера мне сказала
это Регина Почему не делаете 10
ингредиенты перестанет быть
удовольствием и это начнет быть для меня
денежным заработком А когда это только
будет денежным заработком мне это станет
не интересно и поэтому я это не делаю и
все
Кстати
я как раз недавно выступал по поводу по
теме Как сделать эффективную команду с
теми людьми которые у вас есть И один из
аргументов там который я приводил
смотрите команда это такой организм Она
любит когда и ставят сверхзадачи команда
любит нагрузку команда любит скорость но
она не любит
когда много употребляют много
зарабатывают и
команда начинает распадаться Когда Вы
начинаете вознаграждать их деньгами
ювелиркой каким-то предметами
потребления это
[музыка]
помнишь была реклама в 90-х годах когда
захватили константинопо три дня Все
грабили пили насиловали и так далее и он
собрал на площади всех своих воинов
заставил все золотые сережки все
положить с кучу все ювелирку все все
шелка и так далее и все сжёг И после
этого Они захватили мир знаешь Моя
любимая сказка это Маленький принц я в
Америке один из самых больших
коллекционеров у меня там порядка 200
книг
302 языка переведена книга Я знаю
у меня все книги куклы
картинки деньги и франки все с маленьким
принцем Я даже знаю там где
его самолет били тут и Кто сбил
Самолеты
это вторая самая книга после Библии
Библия переведена на 640 языков
Маленький принц 30 последний язык
который был переведен на кабардинский
и Да я вплоть до того знаю где был сбит
самолеты в каком году и какого числа и
сколько лет книги и самое интересное что
первый раз эта книга увидела свет в
Америке а не во Франции во Франции он
был запрещен режим немецких вишей
запретили его издавать и он первый раз
издавался в Америке и Вы только потом
когда немцев одолели только тогда в
сорок шестом году первый раз Она вышла
во Францию Я знаю вообще вот если есть
вещи которых я знаю всё вот я знаю Всё
внутри двигателя внутреннего сгорания и
книги маленький принцип интересно оттуда
что-то берёшь для жизни всё как правило
всё интересно вот это второй человек
первый человек
я знаю Василий Васильевич Анисимова он
миллиардером в нью-йорке живёт
хорошо
Он живёт ровно соседней улице от меня
классный мужик
уехал в Москву бизнес он такой
алюминиевый металлургический
Партнер Дерипаска и он мне говорил
маргулан все что я в этой жизни чему
научился это сказки я читаю только
сказки и я ему не верил Потом он меня
пригласил на юбилей как-то в Москве
2007 или 6 или 5 каких-то тех годах и он
мне подарил вот такую толстый том
красивейший оформленных сказок Я тогда
не впервые убедился он говорит Я же тебе
рассказывал что я всю жизнь вырос на
сказках и бизнес Я говорю на сказках Вот
мои любимые сказки он там тысячу сказок
тысячу там народ рассказывает И он мне
подарил Это я тогда думаю надо же
действительно человека и вот сейчас
слышу что ты на маленьком принце и много
извлекаешь оттуда интересно я знаю еще
одно очень успешного человека кстати в
Америке
у меня с ним похоже знания Нам нравится
Карлос кастанеды да то есть я к тому что
вот я много взрослый сказочник Я много
выступаю Я часто говорю ребята не
переоценивайте
заслугу человека или лектора
я исхожу из того что когда ученик готов
учитель найдется так вот многие Я даже
как-то читал лекцию для коучей они
говорили мне в чем вас секрет почему там
от вас люди получают так много инсайтов
и так далее
всего одна во-первых я подбираю
аудиторию людей которые уже готовы
меняться а во-вторых когда такая
аудитория я могу говорить что угодно они
будут ловить это знаете когда вы
приходите на концерт какого-то юмориста
вы уже от его вида готовы смеяться
потому что вы готовы вы знаете поэтому
когда ученик готов учитель найдется в
моем случае одни книги В твоем случае
маленьким Василий это были сказки то
есть главное самим Быть готовым меняться
я собираю вот у меня я собираю мне три
три коллекции первая коллекция Это все
что связано с маленьким принцем второе
ты сейчас будешь смеяться второе это
клоуны я хотел быть Клоун я хотел идти в
Одесской цирковое училище
мне всегда мои друзья говорили герчик
друзья назвали по фамилии гершель такой
веселый тебя реально цирковое идти там
комедиантом каким-то Ну папа говорит Ну
как вообще представляешь Ты пойдешь
у меня огромная коллекция вообще
огромная со всего мира и третье я
собираю карманные часы
я стал собирать карманные часы песочные
часы у меня карманные часы минимум 100
лет должны быть не самое важное вещь
это обязательно должна быть дарственная
надпись Тогда эта энергетика и то есть я
вот собираю часы например там от папы с
мамой сыну или там
там отёки с дядей там племяннику вот
такого типа у меня все практически часы
подписаны самое интересное никогда не
гонюсь там за каким-то брендом мне не
надо чтобы это было там Патрик Филипп
или чтобы это было Тиффани Я вообще на
это не смотрю я смотрю красивая вещь
была в хорошем состоянии все Почему часы
Я всегда людям всем говорю одно и тоже
ничего дороже времени в жизни ничего И
когда один раз я вел один вебинар У меня
очень красивые песочные часы турецкие
под старину сделаны очень красиво я прям
переворачиваю и вот людям задаю вопрос
большой вебинар 5.000 человек говорю
ребят что это такое Это твоя жизнь вот
это вот каждый Бусинка которая падает и
вы в этот момент просрали Вот вы
просрали просто это время которое назад
невозможно
Мисс самое страшное было чтобы я стал
заложником когда кто-то покупает мое
время
на самом деле я преподаю знаешь какие
вещи я говорю самая самая ценная в этой
жизни этой энергии потому что бывает так
что ты что-то запланировал у тебя время
есть энергия нет то есть бывает так
ситуации что у тебя время есть но
энергии нет поэтому все-таки для того
чтобы не противоречить своим словам
говорю все-таки ребята энергия на первом
месте время где-то подобрать энергию всё
равно время нужно
смотрите если мы спим каждый день 8
часов едим питаемся нормально этого эта
энергия достаточно для того чтобы
достигать любых успехов в этой жизни
например раз в год раз в год я должен
остаться сам собой на две недели
обязательно вот я раз в год остаюсь сам
собой на две недели
Да вот я об этом и говорю там мне вот
эти две недели нужны для того чтобы Да я
просто подключился к какому-то источнику
и все Я вот эту энергию получаю
интересно Александр здесь такой момент
одиночество Это один из самых моих
любимых видов времяпровождения То есть я
а я одиночество очень сильно люблю прямо
я в этом плане не знаю интроверт Может
быть но мне очень кайфово одному думать
размышлять ходить и так далее Вот ты
когда думал всё время у меня голова
лопнула Ну ты вот когда один проводишь
время ты чем занимаешься Нет я вот если
эти две недели За эти 2 недели говорить
спорт с утра до вечера я просыпаюсь в
6:00 утра сижу только на воде то есть
полная разгрузка Да вот когда я на
семинар читали еще что-то мне этого не
хватает потому что мне нужно где-то
откуда-то энергии брать я начинаю жрать
потом уже сегодня сразу идём в шаурму
После этого я пойду с ним две шаурмы
Вчера мы пошли там в узбекское утром я
стою тяжело мне надо Просто потом все я
уезжаю домой я сразу шесть семь
килограмм просто Сажусь я могу 3-4 дня
вообще без еды и без воды мой рекорд был
5 дней без еды и без воды я был ездил в
Карелию Я две недели только спорт Все я
не пытаюсь собой остаться у меня мысли
всегда чистые у меня благие намерения я
никакую хрень не делаю я приезжаю в
любую страну мира я могу ходить везде по
улицам я не боюсь что мне кто-то
подойдёт скажет я никого нет когда не
обманул и никогда никого кинул не кинул
на деньги
много читаешь я читаю только
художественную литературу только
художник никакой технической литературы
фильмы вот то что
сказал ловись его Василий Васильевич я
смотрю только французские кинокомедии Я
не даю своему мозгу вообще напрягаться
если мне хочется знаешь там всегда нужны
такие моменты когда нам надо поплакать
просто вот Ну у меня есть момент есть
книги Я обожаю Ремарк я Ремарка всего
перечитал я начал читать когда не было
наверное лет 17 у нас довольно таки
большая
художественная литература дома была я
перечитал всего Даниэля дф
жюльвентон например
одна из моих самых Да я всего э-э и Том
Сойер и Ну всё Жюль вернется всё
перечитал там ты людям приходишь там
жульен всем всех сразу там 20.000 лет
под водой рыба читали говорит
Таинственный остров и люди начинают вот
для мамы никогда не заставляла Просто у
нас книги были я очень любил
художественную литературу гипербалует
инженер Гарина Да я вам всё очень
фантастика приключения я братья все их
перечитал довольно много литературы я
перечитал Я всегда боюсь чужого мнения
поэтому я стараюсь книги Оля зеланда не
читать Потому что я не знаю как
отреагирует моя психика ты работаешь
живешь на несколько стран получается
[музыка]
культурное пространство политическая
информация все все что варится
и ты больше интересуешься все чем Что
происходит в Америке или другие страны
тоже обязательно я трейдер имеет один
большой плюс трейдер
полностью осматривать всю ситуацию в
мире конъюнктура Например если где-то
начинается тянуться инфляция Она обычно
будет везде в мире тянуться Да но я
например экономический могу обосновать
вряд ли Вообще я думаю ни один экономист
не обоснует например проблему Почему
Соединенные штаты в свое время довели
Евросоюз и почему давили Китай я тебе
гарантирую что 90 процентов экономистов
просто не Не а я расскажу сейчас
американская экономика 23 триллиона там
24 года мы там ожидаем 25 триллионов
следующий после американской экономики
шел Евросоюз 19 триллионов после этого
шли китайцы 16 17 но китайцы стали очень
сильно нагонять потому что китайцы был
очень высоким ВВП порядка семи процентов
А у Америки три с половиной при трапе
было 42 Почти да первое что сделали
американцы для американцев Что самое
главное остаться стороной номер один в
мире
национальная валюта мировая американцы
номер один Что делают американцы первый
шаг brexit вывести Англию пятое самое
крупное экономика в мире вывести из
состава Евросоюза Что делает Трамп там
говорит ребята у вас 250 миллиардов
долларов будет дефицит мы вам его
покроем за счет того то вот это выводит
Англию из брексита Мне становится
отдельной страной и естественно Евросоюз
сразу теряет большой кусок откатывается
назад и Китай тоже самое
экономически не атакуют Японию
5 триллионов 6 триллионов помощь
интересует
до такой степени предельно Просто мне
надо супер умным быть и Россия Россия
к тому что по России по сравнению с
этими цифрами вообще
Да триллион это 80 процентов это
энергоресурс можете сравнить разницу 23
триллиона ВВП США и триллион это Россия
причем из этого триллиона наверное
процентов 80 ресурсов ресурс Ну вот в
этом году
смотрел в этом году смотрел я очень
люблю бюджеты смотреть и все остальное
Как ты думаешь расходы на вооружение в
Америке на 23 год
смотреть Трейдинг многие наверняка
смотрят и им любопытно это часть тоже не
могу обойти Трейдинг всё-таки это больше
Техническая харцкелы или всё-таки
примерно соотношение Ну я 70% техник и
80 процентов наверное Технический анализ
20%, Я просто добираю новостями
когда ты в трейдинге ты волей-неволей
начинаешь какие-то вещи просто понимать
и изучать то есть Это скорее всего
довесок Но я по технике в 80 процентов
случаях определю куда пойдет доля
таланта интуиции они такого талантов не
существует расскажу очень очень
интересную завязку был такой
композитор ференц-лист и он приходит
домой плачет ему было 15 лет и мама
говорит что ты плачешь мама
Представляешь я говорит при 15 часов
практикую секретов фортепиано эти
невежда Называют меня талант
усидчивость дисциплина как сказал
Великий Брюс Ли кто победит себя станет
непобедим
человек для начала должен понимать
почему он хочет прийти в эту индустрии и
что ему надо Вот пример то что мы сидели
моего партнера Антона Антон 14 лет и я
сел занимаемся разработкой
искусственного интеллекта он первый раз
увидел деньги семь лет назад Это был
первый и последний и сейчас вот мы опять
Вот только вышли на тот уровень где он
может приносить какие-то деньги вот
скажи мне какие чувства надо иметь чтобы
14 лет заниматься делом которое пока ты
еще ничего не заработал
любовь То есть если у тебя ты хочешь
кем-то стать
Ты должен понимать одну вещь Что вначале
это не будет приносить деньги то есть ты
хочешь построить что-то большое Ты
должен вот это вот носить постоянно вот
этой лопатой загрузил привез сделал и
потом только что-то большое может
получить так вот 14 лет жизни из 33
половина потратил на то чтобы что-то
получилось не понимая плюс сколько это
денег может стоить и я 7 лет и я пошел с
ним потому что я поверил в него а он
поверил в меня кстати хорошая Ремарка
еще такой момент что такое любовь к
какому-то делу это когда ты занимаешься
этим делом невзирая на шансы на успех ты
можешь бесплатно что-то делать Ты это
любишь Это ты невзирая на шансы на шансы
меня успех не то что там есть большие
шансы я это люблю отказался он свидетель
если 7 лет отказался от проектов на
общую сумму от 30 до 50 млн долларов
в сторону нашего проекта то что я
понимал что я буду тратить очень много
времени у нас есть большая брокерская
фирма у меня мой Партнер Иван занимается
У нас есть большая образовательная у
меня мой Партнер Дима занимается и вот
мы с Антоном Я просто это люблю А что
вот основное внимание творчества
забирает Чем ты занимаешься
по 5 часов в день по семь часов в день
это такое любимое дети что это Расскажи
это искусственный интеллект который по
сути дела Может
заниматься трейдингом То есть он может
правильно определить уровни правильно
определить цену правильно определить
направление движения это алгоритмическая
торговля полностью чисто алгоритм
настоящий искусственный интеллект
математически не нейронные сети где по
сути дела Мы даже никуда не лезем если
люди хотят Им будет интересно у нас
огромное интервью на 45 минут вообще
просто дословно объяснено что это такое
случайное
или алгоритм фиксированный
самообучаемый это когда есть железная
формула ему не надо само обучаться
потому что он приводит То есть то что
происходит на графике оно подходит под
формулу или не подходит у нас нету
нейронной сетей как Антон любит говорить
ты пытаешься в нейронную сеть засунуть
кошечек а на выходе получить собачек ты
получаешь объект а то что делает
название нашего искусственного
интеллекта у него есть определенные
входные данные все пропускается через
алгоритм математические просто чтобы ты
пять лет пять лет только ушло на вывод и
доказательство формул только теория то
есть пять лет занимались только теорий
можете представить То есть как наука Да
может через 10 лет что-то получится
может через 20 ты либо это любишь этим
занимаешься И вот сейчас мы начали
получать плоды к нам естественно тут же
пришли предложили продать
мир не бездумных людей без добрых
и ты знаешь мы даже не рассматривали
вообще слово как продаж потому что мы
задали себе вопрос А что Мы продали Ну
хорошо мы взяли эти деньги
мы взяли просто кусок нашей жизни
моей 15 процентов его половины и просто
продали за какую-то сумму денег тогда
кто-то начинает загореть другой вопрос
Ну вот если вам дали больше не 10
миллионов примеру А 30 миллионов ребят
если нам сейчас дали 30 миллионов то
через год мы все равно сто процентов
получим Мы хотим выжить по максимуму
Например у нас наш искусственный
интеллект наш жир он может
обрабатывать новости вот Регина которая
вчера была она просто за это зацепилась
вы мне Расскажите Я очень хочу Мне
просто интересно вот обрабатывать
новости мы просто сейчас так как мы оба
профессионалы в трейдинге он тоже
трейдер мы
пока его направили в сторону трейдинга
но он умеет делать абсолютно все ему
только нужны входные данные вот он умеет
обрабатывать вот дашь хороший выходные
данные на выходе то же самое получше это
вот страсть Я обожаю преподавать но
4-5 раз в год когда это становится
больше все у нас большая брокерская
компания почему Например мы с Иваном
моим партнером который живет в Дубае
открыли брокерскую компанию и Дмитрий
мой другой Партнер мы занимаемся
образованием У нас очень большой спрос
особенно ковид когда был люди стали
учиться Потому что люди понимают одну
вещь что-то случается в мире бухие нет
бизнеса
раз нету бизнес А тут ты взял компьютер
у нас Мы даже 180 долларов прицепной
кран ты приехал в любую точку мира
прицепил два экрана у тебя полноценный
компьютер и все ты сел Да вот сейчас мы
с Антоном улетаем в Дубаи вместе
встречаемся там обсуждаем разные вещи
все
[музыка]
вот еще такой вопрос я уверен Наверняка
у многих наверное языке вертится в
отношении криптовалютам И как ты к этому
вообще торгуешь не торгуешь я
криптовалютам отношусь только купил
продал заработал всё никакого
оптимизма никакого пессимизма никакой
влюбленности когда я пришел Трейдинг
ничего более Да обмен заработал 24 года
назад трейдить мне сказали одну вещь
никогда не Влюбляйся в инструмент ни в
какой и вот это мне очень сильно бесит И
вообще это слово не люблю но меня бесит
когда просто из каждой дыр кто-то мне
начинает писать мне вот тут сказали
можно зарабатывать 300 процентов день
знаешь есть хороший анекдот когда
мужчина 75 лет приходит доктор Вы знаете
я хочу заниматься сексом как мой сосед
сколько вашему соседа 74 он говорит и
сколько раз сексом занимается людей Он
говорит Четыре раза откуда вы знаете он
говорит он мне сказал говорите тоже
Да и я понимаю одну вещь Что есть люди в
объяснить и люди в это начинают себя
ответить там Bitcoin пошел до 17000 все
надо покупать он будет 50 и люди
начинают просто вот это в это Свято
верить и все вдруг откуда-то появлялась
огромное какое-то количество людей
кто-то нас смотрит скажет например ты
наверное нам завидуешь чему
я вчера для твоей группы делал
презентацию я ребята показал две акции
одна дала 10 иксов за два месяца 10
иксов не надо криптовалютным Гуру быть
телеграм-канале в Инстаграме
всегда если относиться к этому как
обыкновенному инструменту заработка Да
но популяризировать на каждом шагу новые
тема сейчас p2p
Арбитраж делал 20 лет назад я знаю
абсолютно все что
Арбитраж там на акциях между акциями
между секторами
Арбитраж бывает между странами какого
здесь то же самое только это между
биржами технологиями между бирже с одной
где-то схватил где-то с другой люди не
понимают одну вещь 3-4 месяца там где
будут обороты зайдут фонды это все
выкушается там такие ребята эммайтишные
сидят как пионер фон Да там писать негде
рядом вообще там приходит пацаны ты не
понимаешь они выходят у меня мальчик
вышел самоты Ну гений Это это ничего не
сказать ему дали 200 тысяч долларов на
старт зарплату сразу после и 200.000
долларов или локацию только чтобы он в
неё переехал он только закончил идти
гений Это всё круто это да надо и нужно
восхищаться но в то же время помните Ну
я часть тоже об этом говорю
инвестор Этот человек который ко всему
относится с небольшим скепсисом
История это подтверждает У нас есть
которые
два нобелевских лауреата и грохнулся все
что они сделали они произвели самый
большой шум на рынке это государство их
спасало или спасли
добью твою историю
80 процентов денег были потеряны за 4
часа на дефолте России
80 процентов денег два нобелевских
это
поражение
все лучшие технологии были там самое
главное люди должны понимать везде
бизнес Трейдинг все что угодно отношения
мужчина женщина одна ключевая фраза Все
может быть
а они сказали этого не может быть да да
ты всегда должен иметь долю пессимизма
знаешь когда
самолет разбился и на необитаемом
острове
оказывается пессимист оптимист но
оптимист говорит Ну все хуже уже не
будет свист говорит будет доля ты
правильно сказал скептицизма и
пессимизма всегда должна быть иначе ты
не сможешь адекватно думать однозначно
Более того я часто говорю
помимо фразы Все может быть там есть еще
продолжение фразы может быть еще и
остальное
И вот например у нас есть годовая
программа в трейдинге обучения Да самый
популярный Почему Потому что человек вот
за ручку Берут у тебя Да и тебя вести
начинают Почему если ты где-то какой-то
там
В класс не пришел или еще что-то у тебя
это звено не сойдется Да И вот мы
сделали годовую программу пришел один
студент
студенты учат нас всему больше всех вот
он пришел студент и говорит Шеф мне
чуть-чуть не хватило Можно
дополнительные уроки Давайте сделайте
годовую программу я первую вас буду и
благодаря у нас твой парень был Андрей
ди года благодаря ему родилась годовая
программа и всё и человек приходит и ему
моя задача вот эти за 12 месяцев
выстроить чтобы он был самостоятельной
единицы чтобы он не поднимал Александр
Михайлович что делать
что делать но чтобы он сказал так вот у
меня тетрадка написано первый второй
третий четвёртый раз я открыл посмотрел
что делать ради этого люди идут
Почему в университете учат 5 лет
Потому что твоя голова физически дали 20
предметов в день ты физически ничего
сделать не сможешь это как раз Кстати на
вопрос мне часто задают вопрос марган
критику много читаете говорит А почему
вы не освоились скорочтение Вот я говорю
проблема не в всасывании текста проблема
в понимании то есть научиться быстро
читать то я могу но узкая это горлышко
надо обдумать и понять чтобы цель другая
поэтому скорочтение это для
коллекционеров которые хотят выглядеть
немного эрудитами которые типа да я
читал эту книжку
ты покупаешь либо красивый либо те
которые пахнут вот я не куплю те которые
красиво
цветы цветы должны пахнуть машина должна
ездить самолет должен летать птица
должна летать
ребята которые у нас камеры снимает Вот
они выставили камеры на глазок А сколько
таких камер предоставляли на глазу Вот
это и есть профессионализм
профессионализм в этом именно и
заключается в том что ты делаешь
обдуманное действие очень много раз
какой смысл попытаться быстро прочитать
книгу чтобы потом сказать я прочитал
своей жизни 6 тысяч книг но я нихера не
запомнил Я практически все книги которые
я читал там
запомнил но ничего не понял Да я в своей
жизни все книги которые я прочитал да я
могу сказать например ты читал Даниэля
Дефо
Граф монтехни Да больше такого острова
Он убежал Ну это неважно
Ты вот этот фильм смотрел Да что такое
знакомое название все фильмы которые я
смотрел я помню до цитата начиная Москва
слезам не верит заканчивая Вокзал для
двоих и все остальные фильмы все у меня
даже
компьютере есть Папочка мои любимые
вырезки из каждого фильма у меня
специально обученные люди я вырезаю мои
любимые моменты Просто потом смотрю там
Хороший год и все остальное как у тебя
память такая у меня не память такая
Просто в тот момент я хотел это я это
получил У меня мозг запомнил все И когда
люди приходят в трейдинге Ребята это
техническая литература тут работают
четыре момента Первое это восприятие
второе это понимание
третье это Запоминание и четвертое это
воспроизведение так устроен мозг ты не
затолкаешь никогда в жизни информацию
ребят книгу нужно сначала три раза
прочитать просто художественную
литературу просто перелистывать Почему
Потому что мозга задача это лечь на
кровати взять Баночку пива и вот так вот
лежать и отдыхать Мозга нет задачи чтобы
он постоянно работал его напрягать надо
и все я объясняю это художественная
литература когда мы с Антоном
познакомились он и просто выломал мозг
ты не понимаешь он физик математик вот
пирожные которые ты ел его супруги и
вкусно было да
и он значит не говорит вот мне честно
сказал это 7 лет назад был ему 25 лет
было и может себе представить я уже мне
там 44 Я состоявшийся взрослый мужик там
мультимиллионер все я понимаю что если
мы идем я должен подчиняться системе не
ему
надо почитать одну книжку
дочь структуры реальности
знаешь я тебе скажу честно когда начал
сложно когда начал читать первый раз и
такое ощущение было что мне взяли Колы
вбили в голову Потом значит он мне
говорит Я сейчас вам дам две книги Ну
первое это структура реальности и он не
говорит я вам сейчас дам вырезки он мне
дает она считает читать я думаю
43 года 44 года мужику состоялся чистый
поц
вообще и он говорит Ну вы просто должны
понимать как работает потому что это
идея это ему было я уже вторичный
продукт Я начала добавлять трейдинговые
штучки в неё я понял одну вещь То есть
ты хочешь в чем-то разобраться должен
подчиняться системе вообще всегда во
всем системы у тебя дома в семье законы
у тебя по отношению к родителям закона
определённые Нравится не нравится твоя
мама Она твоя мама папа это твой папа
родители не выбирают мы во всем всегда
должны быть системными вот это то что
мне нравится у тебя ты пытаешься
симпатизировать все вот есть кружок вот
твоя задача завести в кружок закрыть
двери и вот в этом кружке они должны по
кругу Серебряный дворик Вот они вот так
вот ходят
что для тебя деньги ничего
спорт Я люблю зарабатывать отвечу другим
вопросам на вопрос значит буквально в
недавно мне задали вопрос Любите ли вы
деньги от этого пойдем я сказал Окей
Например я люблю свою семью реально я
ради своей семьи сделаю все вот мне надо
было бы почку отдать Я бы отдал у меня
сосед отдал почву своей дочке прямо мой
сосед соседнего дома сделал бы это
вообще даже не задумался Что я сделал
ради денег ничего значит я не люблю а
уважаю для меня деньги я их люблю
зарабатывать я их не ворую Я никогда
никого не отнимаю для меня деньги это
автомобиль передвижения больше денег
качественнее автомобиль меньше денег
автомобиль меньше качество то есть Много
заработал передвигаешься на rolls-royce
В смысле не rolls-royce
rolls-royce как машина Просто у тебя
более качество передвижения летаешь
бизнес-классом там
одежда вообще Вот честно ничего нет я
ничего не ношу я
ювелирные изделия У меня очень много
часов я не ношу там не понадарили
коллекцию Я люблю машины Я одеваюсь
очень кривые вчера пришел одета красиво
Специально для вас сегодня я понял что
зачем я буду одеваться если все
одеваются простенько я взял Я видел
джинсы Я обожаю я очень много лет был в
корпоративной индустрии Я терпеть не мог
рубашки и 200 штук Это 250 и я видел
вчера я пришёл Я же уважать людей
которым я читаю лекцию Просто я могу
выйти конечно как холодильник
миллионер я могу ходить как я хочу быть
в трусах но когда ты выходишь и люди
тебя слушают Ты должен иметь к ним
уважение это нормально Ну вчера я видел
что все это по спортивному Я всё тоже по
спортивному естественно тоже оделся то
есть одежда для меня вообще ничего не
значит деньги это
это возможность там
давать себе и своей семье возможность
жить так как мы хотим Но
переступил бы я свои интересы ради
каких-то других денег никогда и самое
интересное кто-то может сказать Наверное
вам мало предлагали немного предлагали
много я уходил с возрасте где у меня
были миллионные заработки в виде зарплат
Ну то есть просто компенсация Я когда
уходил с компанией мне партнеры останься
там консультации все
это как водка завязал значит завязал Да
на этой оптимистичной ноте наверное
Позвольте завершить все-таки
Эфирное время не резиновое и внимание
наших телезрителей или YouTube зрителей
тоже не бесконечно классный разговор Я
думаю что это рыба была абсолютно другим
Мне кажется ребята даже со стороны
иногда улыбались приятно было мне
кажется мы зацепили вообще абсолютно все
здесь мне всегда кажется вот я все время
пытаюсь принизить значение бизнеса
заработков денег смотрите это такая же к
такой же вид деятельности это работа
инвестиция тоже работа есть всегда вы от
этого получаете Азарт то это не
инвестиции а казино по сути
[музыка]
твои проблемы всегда и Трейдинг то же
самое
если человек приходит психологическими
комплексами все это знаешь что я всегда
говорю погиб Трейдинг на 3 месяца ты
будешь о себе знать больше чем ты знаешь
за всю жизнь абсолютно Вот это это один
из самых важных кстати классные книги
сразу можем порекомендовать но для меня
моя Одна из любимых книг в плане
трейдинга это революция
это кстати брал интервью швайдера
персонального
В общем 5 лет назад интервью у меня есть
на канале приезжай
никогда в жизни ни одного человека не не
приводил к себе домой в общем короче мы
с Димой садимся на джип берём джип
Швайгер никогда никому не давал он давал
много интервью русскоязычно никогда в
общем я звоню Я представился говорю
Пожалуйста проверьте
он говорит я в Колорадо болдер Граф
Приезжайте мы приезжаем домой прямо
спустили домой У него две огромные вот
такие вот собаки очень любят собак А он
просто море обаяние если не могу
передать у него такая хорошая Аура
энергетика и у меня сидит и начинаем
спрашивать интервью у меня есть на
канале Я говорю скажи мне как-то вот эту
книгу писал и тут мне говорит Ну я тебя
разочарую Я в графиках вообще ничего не
понимаю
Я клянусь в интервью мне просто стояли
надо написать книгу
я был заказ и показали пальцем там мне
все принесли у кого были я уже
нескольких людей он был из барселина
Стив колоджан
все со мной дружит меня даже на чеках
биржу приглашали я летал туда и мы вот
сильно там дружим сильно вообще отец
просили на папу бандит был мафио да да
они украли две тонны серебра где-то там
и продавали ходили по улицам потом это
люди очень интересные он мне тогда
сказал я сижу думаю
книга там бестселлер и все остальное
человек мне такое говорит Ну я тебе
говорю правду как есть все книжку писал
про графики не понимаю просто у паттерны
там написал
можно так Market withers мастера рынка
[музыка]
лучшими играми
3 у него чисто Технический анализ
Посмотрите книги
именно в виде истории там не такие
скучные книги там истории
Воспоминания биржевого спекуляции это
просто шикарная книга не знаю Я ее
перечитывал очень
Расскажи у него Он же женился на женщине
у которой четыре мужа до этого покончили
жизнь самоубийством
это знаю он просто пошел против от там
даже потом Шутка была да что четыре жены
которые него до этого были покончили
жизнь самоубийством Всем уже и он был 5
который застрелился это всем вам очень
хороший урок Да если у жены с первым
мужем что-то случилось Будьте очень
аккуратно
хороший лайфхак хорошая беседа Спасибо
Да можно в этой жизни смотреть на три
вещи это на воду на огонь и как
Александр герчик
Спасибо большое Александр может быть
что-нибудь подарим нашим зрителям
Давай сделаем так вот
ты выберешь потом самое лучшее вещь
которую ты хочешь мы дадим 5 подарков
Так у нас будет очень много людей
смотреть дать как-то один подарок по
нищебродски тем более скоро буду Новый
год уровень 5 подарков всем людям
которые напишут самый интересный самый
профессиональный самый лучший подарок
знаешь какой у нас будет
самый дорогой в марте месяце у нас будет
семинар в Алмате это посещение бесплатно
семинара в Алмате
самое главное из пяти подарков будет
посещение бесплатно посещения семинара в
Алмате
полноценный с одним днем реальных торгов
он будет по-моему если не память не
изменяет там со 2 марта по-моему пять
дней Да ты естественно приглашен в любой
момент
это я думаю самый лучший подарок ты
выберешь вообще все что ты считаешь
нужным скажешь мы дадим подписку на джер
Да обязательно
годовую подписку дадим подписку У нас
есть telegram-канал скорее всего и
подарим ещё один курс от а до я
естественно
бесплатный поход на семинар Так что
ребята Будьте активны пишите комментарии
и комментарии еще раз подчеркну мы будем
оценивать с точки зрения
профессиональной
профессионализма интересности и
эмоциональности поэтому пишите не просто
ставьте лайки круто и так далее что-то
более содержательное будут лайки не
будет курсов
тоже нужны лайки подписка это Must have
поэтому я имею ввиду что мы сегодня
очень много просто задушины 70 процентов
по душам говорили это поэтому это самое
главное для них чтобы они понимали Да
это если душа пустая человек не сможет
сам собой договориться
это наш искусственный интеллект который
дает сигналы по трейдингу и после Нового
года Будет поддерживать доверительное
управление
смотрите есть два две вещи два аспекта
этого вопроса от первого управлять
собственным капиталом и второй управлять
чужим капиталом так вот не научившись
управлять собственный капиталом чужой
капитал брать ни в коем случае нельзя ни
в коем случае Но если управлять
собственный капиталом то наверное прежде
всего нужно понять
такую вещь приходит благо
в моем понимании приходит от взятия
риска и проявления терпения то есть
основа зарабатывания на инвестициях если
бы брать про инвестиции второе это
обеспечить выживаемость никогда не
делать в одну ставку все деньги не
ставьте потому что в конечном итоге
Выигрывает тот кто дольше остался в игре
и третий момент четко понимаете С чего
вы зарабатываете если вы зарабатываете с
Актива то следите за активом за ее
прибыльностью за показателем этого
актива и так далее если вы зарабатываете
с другого человека то есть на повышение
цены значит вы зарабатываете с другого
человека тогда все внимание обращайте не
на актив А на поведение и настроение
толпы людей общее настроение в обществе
поэтому я могу вот так разве что
делаешь что любишь
ты не можешь навредить
съемка своего маму жену ты не можешь
навредить все так же самой бизнес Если
ты любишь свой бизнес ты будешь уходит
ли ходит лелеет жалеет баловать и все
остальное
кейс из студентов на сегодняшний день
вот приведу пример Я всегда боюсь когда
у студента очень быстро все получается у
меня есть на сегодняшний день один из
студентов ему будет наверное Катя зовут
Андрей Свешников живет в Португалии и
вот он полтора года просто вот железной
задницей вытягивал Все у него там это не
получалось то не получалось но он всегда
с первого и до последнего по сегодняшний
день он как раз у меня учится второй год
на годовой программе
он
мегадисциплинированный он Мега
исполнительный он Мега послушный И самое
главное Мега открыты когда у него были
проблемы всегда разговариваю и вот
сейчас он меня вышел на уровень тире
2000 долларов в день чистого заработка
каждый день он мне там буквально там
несколько недель назад прислал СМСку Вот
это наверное у меня много очень очень
толковых ребят но это чем хорошо Это
человек знает что он хочет как он хочет
И что он готов сделать для получения
результата круто реально хороший Я тоже
не очень люблю всегда настораживать
когда в начале все получается Обычно
потом включается и все начинает клинить
и тебе надо чинить сразу а вот такие
люди как ты сказал это редкость реально
большая везде и бизнесе тоже
91 процент по американским меркам в
бизнесе закрывается в первый год
вот уже люди просто не готовы
Я смотрел очень много бизнес-планов
через шесть месяцев выйти на
самоокупаемость вот у нас кофейня наш
рост раздувает Мы вышли на саму
окупаемость через два месяца это
называется повезло это чудо это
открылись правильном месте правильное
время это просто повезло Ставил бы я
ставку на то что бизнес выйдет на самом
окупаемость через два месяца никогда
никогда с другой стороны везение Это
хорошо сделано домашняя работа Правильно
мы естественно готовились место
подбиралось делается хороший ремонт
повезло
все три другие кофейни Открой Буду
надеяться через два месяца я заложу
денег на год вперёд и буду их высиживать
все раз быстрее хорошо Нет я буду ждать
чтобы оставаться эффективным и не терять
себя
Давайте Александру зададим
я повторюсь надо просто любить то что ты
делаешь и делаешь то что любишь все Если
ты любишь свое дело Ты всегда будешь
счастлива счастье это то что порождает
Вот это состояние все Да ты пошел в
шуруй говоря часы думаешь пойдем кушать
шаурму Да писать люди сейчас скажет вот
нищеброда со своими миллионами пойдут
кушать шаурму У меня есть один друг
казах Нурлан он в колумбийском
университете учился в Америке очень
много лет жил мы сегодня с Антоном
должны его тоже увидеть специально
прилетел увидеться
я могу смотреть два варианта вариант
первый
вечером
конечно же урму
просто люди должны понимать эту вещь
человек должен быть счастливым в любом
проявлении в любом всегда просто держите
в голове основная моя
счастливее или нет Вот это самое
вопросов просто вот любовь конек плохо
никогда не получится вот Папа всю жизнь
мне говорил одну вещь говорит Сделай
Хорошо Плохо получится само по себе да
автоматически
хорошо спасибо на этом Александр